Guys know how much I love my healthy soda,
especially without all the crap in it.
So today we're gonna taste test some poppies.
These are my five favorite flavors.
I just have never ranked them.
So let's see what we have.
We have the orange one, and we have the grape Poppy,
ginger lime,
cherry limeade, and the raspberry rose.
I love these
because they have less than 5 grams of sugar,
and they also have a prebiotic,
which is really good for your gut.
And they also have apple cider vinegar in them.
Let's start with the orange.
I think this is my absolute favorite one. Yes!
That is so good.
It's probably third place.
Fourth place. I know this is probably gonna be second.
Uh huh. Then I think this is Lucky's favorite flavor.
That is so good.
Haven't had the cherry limeade in a minute,
so this is third.
I think this is how I'd rank them.
This one's my absolute favorite.
Then I love the raspberry rose.
Cherry lime,
a ginger lime,
and then the grape.
These are so good.
If you want a soda alternative
and you don't wanna be drinking
all the sugar that's in the soda,
these are great.
Let me know if you've tried them
and what your favorite flavor is.